[Music]
my straw
reaches
across
the room
and starts to drink your milkshake
i drink your
milkshake
i drink it up let's talk about how
movies look movies are first and
foremost a visual medium and on set
cinematographers set up the angles the
lighting and the look of what's being
captured on camera cinematography is
about how we see movies and the best
cinematography award has been a thing
for as long as the oscars have been
around
[Music]
by 1940 the award had permanently split
into two one for black and white and the
other for films in color 1966 was the
final time the academy made that
distinction though black and white
movies have won the oscar three times
since
[Music]
these are the highest rated certified
fresh movies to win an award for best
cinematography meaning they needed to
receive the critics seal of approval to
make it in our list these movies are not
only fantastic but they are as they say
eye candy so let's count down some of
the best cinematography movies ranked by
tomato meter
[Music]
starting with number 10 hugo
orphan it alone except for an uncle hugo
cabre lives in the walls of a train
station in 1930s paris hugo's job is to
oil and maintain the station's clocks
but to him his more important task is to
protect a broten automaton and notebook
left to him by his late father
accompanied by the goddaughter of an
embittered toy merchant hugo embarks on
a quest to solve the mystery of the
automaton and find a place that he can
call home starring ben kingsley asa
butterfield chloe grace moretz and
directed by martin scorsese with
cinematography by robert richardson
critics say hugo is an extravagant
elegant fantasy with an innocence
lacking in many modern kids movies and
one that emanates in unabashed love for
the magic of cinema
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number nine to catch a thief
notorious cat burglar john robbie has
long since retired to 10 vineyards on
the french riviera when a series of
robberies is committed in his style jon
must clear his name armed with a list of
people who own the most expensive jewels
currently in the area jon begins
following the first owner young francie
when her jewels are stolen francie
suspects jon destroying their tentative
romance jon goes on the lamb to catch
the thief and clear his own name
starring cary grant grace kelly jesse
royce landis and directed by alfred
hitchcock with cinematography by robert
burks critics say it may occasionally be
guilty of coasting on pure charm but to
catch a thief has it in spades as well
as a pair of perfectly matched stars in
cary grant and grace kelly
give them back to me
what did you have in mind francine give
them back to me mothers jews
[Music]
i don't have them
when did it happen
when i was asleep let's look there's
only one place to look and that's
obviously here help yourself
did you see francie
did she tell you what happened yes she's
downstairs searching my room that
doesn't make sense she said she knew
where my jewelry was oh she was wrong
may i look into your bedroom if you
think you'll do any good but don't you
think we ought to call the police the
hotel manager you know they always like
to get in on these things but would you
let me look around first mr stephen i
don't care i'd be just as happy if you
didn't find anything
why'd you say that
oh i'm a little tired of draping those
things over me it was exciting at first
but you know now i think it's more
exciting to have them stolen
number eight close encounters of the
third kind
science fiction adventure about a group
of people who attempt to contact alien
intelligence roy neary witnesses an
unidentified flying object and even has
a sunburn from its bright lights to
prove it roy refuses to accept an
explanation for what he saw and is
prepared to give up his life to pursue
the truth about ufos starring richard
dreyfuss francois truffau terry garr and
directed by steven spielberg with
cinematography by vilmos sigmond critics
say close encounters of the third kind
is deeply humane sci-fi exploring male
obsession cosmic mysticism and music
[Music]
so
[Music]
number seven my fair lady
in this beloved musical pompous fanatics
professor henry higgins is so sure of
his abilities that he takes it upon
himself to transform a cockney class
girl into someone who can pass for a
cultured member of high society his
subject turns out to be the lovely eliza
doolittle who agrees to speech lessons
to improve her job prospects higgins and
eliza clash then form an unlikely bond
one that is threatened by an
aristocratic suitor starring audrey
hepburn rex harrison stanley holloway
and directed by george q core with
cinematography by harry stradling
critics say george cucor's elegant
colorful adaptation of the beloved stage
play is elevated to new heights thanks
to winning performances by audrey
hepburn and rex harrison
the rain
in spain
stays mainly
in the plane
what was that
the rain
in spain stays mainly
in the plain
again
the rain in spain stays mainly in the
plane
i think she's got it
i think she's got it
number six pans
labyrinth in 1944 spain young ophelia
and her ailing mother arrive at the post
of her mother's new husband a sadistic
army officer who's trying to quell a
gorilla uprising while exploring an
ancient maze ophelia encounters the
fontpan who tells her that she's a
legendary lost princess and must
complete three dangerous tasks in order
to claim immortality starring sergey
lopez maribel verdu ivana baquero and
directed by guillermo del toro with
cinematography by guillermo navarro
critics say pan's labyrinth is alice in
wonderland for grown-ups with the
horrors of both reality and fantasy
blended together in an extraordinary
spell-binding fable
[Applause]
oh
number five an american in paris
jerry mulligan is an american xgi who
stays in post-war paris to become a
painter and falls for the game charms of
lis bouvier however his paintings come
to the attention of milo roberts a rich
american heiress who is interested in
more than just art starring gene kelly
leslie karen nina fosh and directed by
vincente minelli with cinematography by
alfred gilkes and john alton critics say
the plot in an american in paris may be
problematic but such concerns are
rendered superfluous by gene kelly and
leslie karen's star power the gershwin's
classic songs and vincente minnelli's
colorful sympathetic directions
[Applause]
[Music]
new jersey
[Music]
i can understand disregarding
perspective to achieve an effect
but in your case i believe that why
don't you be a good little girl and move
on you're not gonna buy anything you're
just blocking out the sunshine well i
just wanted to discuss your work i don't
want you to discuss my work
i'm not interested in your opinion of my
work
if you say something nice it won't make
me feel any better and if you don't
it'll bother me thank you good day
number four gravity
dr ryan stone is a medical engineer on
her first shuttle mission her commander
is veteran astronaut matt kowalski
helming his last flight before
retirement then during a routine
spacewalk by the pair disaster strikes
the shuttle is destroyed leaving ryan
and matt stranded in deep space with no
link to earth and no hope of rescue as
fear turns to panic they realize the
only way home may be to venture further
in space starring sandra bullock george
clooney ed harris and directed by
alfonso cuaron with cinematography by
emmanuel lubesky critics say alfonso
quadron's gravity is an eerie tense
sci-fi thriller that's masterfully
directed and visually stunning explore
our permission to retrieve dr stone
houston
all right we've lost houston
we've lost houston
look we need to get the hell out of here
no don't wait for
us out
is
you need to detach i can't see you
anymore
number three the bridge on the river
kwai
the bridge on the river kwai is an
adaptation of the pierre bull novel it's
about prisoners of war in burma forced
to build a bridge to aid the war effort
of their japanese captors british and
american officers plot to blow up the
structure but the commander of the
bridges construction has different plans
starring william holden alec guinness
susu hayakawa and directed by david lean
with cinematography by jack hildyard
critics say the bridge on the river kwai
is a complex war epic that asks hard
questions resists easy answers and
boasts career defining work from star
alec guinness and director david lean
honestly clipton there are times when i
don't understand you at all
i'll try to make myself clear sir
the fact is what we're doing could be
construed as
forgive me sir collaboration with the
enemy
perhaps even as reasonable activity are
you all right clipton we are prisoners
of war we haven't the right to refuse
work i understand that sir must we work
so well must we build them a better
bridge than they could have built for
themselves
if you had to operate on sayeto would
you do your best or would you let him
die
would you prefer to see this battalion
disintegrate in idleness would you have
it said that our chaps can't do a proper
job
don't you realize how important it is to
show these people that they can't break
us in body or in spirit
take a good look clifton
one day the war will be over and i hope
that the people who use this bridge in
years to come
will remember how it was built and who
built it not a gang of slaves but
soldiers british soldiers clipton even
in captivity yes you're a fine doctor
clifton but you've a lot to learn about
the army
number two crouching tiger hidden dragon
in 19th century qing dynasty china a
warrior gives his sword green destiny to
his lover to deliver to safe keeping but
it is stolen and the chase is on to find
it the search leads to the house of you
where the story takes on a whole
different level starring cho young fat
michelle yo zhang zhiyi and directed by
angley with cinematography by peter
powell critics say the movie that
catapulted angley into the ranks of
upper echelon hollywood filmmakers
crouching tiger hidden dragon features a
deft mix of amazing martial arts battles
beautiful scenery and tasteful drama
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
blade runner 2049
officer k a new blade runner for the los
angeles police department unearths a
long buried secret that has the
potential to plunge what's left of
society into chaos his discovery leads
him on a quest to find rick deckard a
former blade runner who's been missing
for 30 years starring ryan gosling
harrison ford anna de armas and directed
by denny villeneuve with cinematography
by roger deakins critics say visually
stunning and narratively satisfying
blade runner 2049 deepens and expands
its predecessor story while standing as
an impressive filmmaking achievement in
its own right
what
there will be blood
silver miner daniel plainview leads a
hard scrabble life with his son hw when
he hears about oil oozing from the
ground near the western town of little
boston daniel takes his son on a mission
to find their fortune daniel makes his
lucky strike and becomes a self-made
tycoon but as his fortune grows he
deviates into moral bankruptcy starring
daniel day-lewis paul dano kevin j
o'connor and directed by paul thomas
anderson with cinematography by robert
ellsworth critics say widely touted as a
masterpiece there will be blood is a
sparse and sprawling epic about the
underhanded heroes of capitalism that
boasts incredible performances by leads
daniel day lewis and paul dano and is
director paul thomas anderson's best
work to date
[Music]
don't get too hot
so
[Music]
what are you thinking so miserable about
the whole ocean of oil under our feet
no one can get that except for me
life of pie
after deciding to sell their zoo in
india and move to canada santosh and
gita patel board a freighter with their
sons and a few remaining animals tragedy
strikes when a terrible storm sinks the
ship leaving the patel's teenage son pie
as the only human survivor however pie
is not alone a fearsome bengal tiger has
also found refuge aboard the lifeboat as
days turn into weeks and weeks drag into
months pi and the tiger must learn to
trust each other if both are to survive
starring saraj sharma irfan khan taboo
and directed by angli with
cinematography by claudio miranda
critics say a 3d adaptation of a
supposedly unfilmable book angley's life
of pie achieves the near impossible it's
an astonishing technical achievement
that's also emotionally rewarding
my name is pipertail
i have been in a shipwreck
i am on a lifeboat alone
with the tiger
please send help
uh
[Music]
and finally number one apocalypse now
in vietnam in 1970 captain willard takes
a perilous and increasingly
hallucinatory journey upriver to find
and terminate colonel kurtz a once
promising officer who has reportedly
gone completely mad in the company of a
navy patrol boat filled with street
smart kids a surfing obsessed air
cavalry officer and a crazed freelance
photographer willard travels further and
further into the heart of darkness
starring marlon brando martin sheen
robert duvall and directed by francis
ford coppola with cinematography by
vittorio ceraro critics say francis ford
coppola's haunting hallucinatory vietnam
war epic apocalypse now is cinema at its
most audacious and visionary
[Music]
nothing else in the world smells like
that
i love the smell of my palm in the
morning
you know one time we had a hail bomb
for 12 hours when it was all over i
walked up
we didn't find one of them not one
stinking big body
smell you know that gasoline smell
a whole hill
smells like
victory
someday this war's gonna end
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you